hoffnung auf normalität die größte
impfaktion in der geschichte
deutschlands ist bundesweit gestartet
debatte um impf privilegien politiker
lehnen mehr freiheiten für geimpfte etwa
in restaurants oder auf reisen ab und
zurück aus der korona quarantäne
skispringer karl geiger soll wieder
starten rechtzeitig zur
vierschanzentournee
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den zdf-nachrichten am sonntag diesmal
mit norbert lehmann an meiner seite ist
alles wunderbar durch von mir ein paar
länder in europa waren ja gestern schon
vorgeprescht wie zum beispiel auch
sachsen anhalt bei uns doch heute hat
das impfen ganz offiziell und überall
begonnen eine aktion mit der sich große
hoffnungen verbinden sie sei der
schlüssel raus aus der pandemie
twitterte gesundheitsminister sparen bis
zum ende des jahres stehen hierzulande
1,3 millionen impfdosen bereit
zuerst kommen menschen in alten und
pflegeheimen sowie personen über 80
jahre dran
dann werden über 70 jährige sowie
menschen mit hohem risiko für einen
schweren krankheitsverlauf geimpft die
dritte gruppe sind unter anderem die
über 60 jährigen mitarbeiter von
verfassungsorganen polizei und
bundeswehr
petra meyer berichtet
ein kleiner pieks der so viel hoffnung
bedeutet karin sievers ist heute morgen
die erste in hamburg die den impfstoff
gegen das corona virus gespritzt bekommt
hamburgs erster bürgermeister peter
tschentscher fährt die 84 jährige danach
persönlich vor die tür
für sie ist die impfung eine gute sache
kurz vorher war der impfstoff der
unternehmen biontech und pfizer unter
besonderer bewachung im hospital zum
heiligen geist angeliefert worden
heute werden 500 chargen verabreicht in
drei wochen muss dann ein zweites mal
geimpft werden
noch ist der impfstoff schwer zu
handhaben die herausforderin einmal der
impfstoffe gekühlt gelagert werden muss
der gips kühlketten mit
unterschiedlichen haltbarkeitsdaten die
müssen eingehalten werden
der impfstoff ist nicht so ganz leicht
zu verarbeiten beim aufziehen und
verdünnen auch in sachsen ging es heute
los in speziell eingerichteten imf
räumen wie hier im seniorenheim
lichtentanne bekommen bewohnerinnen und
belegschaft die erste impfung die
infektionszahlen sind hoch im freistaat
ein viertel der pflegeeinrichtungen
sollen von corona infektionen betroffen
sein
ich sage es mal ein bisschen so ist ein
weihnachtsgeschenk was wir heute
bekommen haben weil es einfach so ein
stück hoffnung gibt in hohenbrunn
riemerling bei münchen ist die
erleichterung spürbar im pflegezentrum
lore malsch wollen sich von den 130
bewohnern rund 90 prozent impfen lassen
es geht ja darum hier im haus eine
herdenimmunität zu erreichen dass wenn
wir einen corona fall haben und dies
nicht mehr so schwer betrifft wie bisher
für eine herdenimmunität müssen sich
etwa zwei drittel der menschen impfen
lassen
bis ende märz sollen in deutschland 13
millionen impfungen zur verfügung stehen
früher als erwartet geht also das impfen
los wir haben gerade den beginn der
aktion in hamburg gesehen
ralf zimmermann von siewert war für uns
dabei wie ist der start zu bewerten
ja gerade das ist ein großer schritt im
hinblick auf mehr freiheiten wieder bei
zwischenmenschlichen kontakt gerade in
den alten und pflegeeinrichtung wir sind
hier in hamburg in einer einrichtung in
hamburg poppenbüttel ist es natürlich
unglaublich wichtig für die menschen
wieder kontakte mehr kontakte pflegen zu
können und nicht mehr isoliert zu sein
gerade für die alten menschen die über
80-jährigen die jetzt dran sind mit dem
impfen so die heute noch mal betont von
politikern von medizinern auch hier in
hamburg die eigentlich überraschend
schnell ist jetzt zum schluss gegangen
ist man hatte ja vor wenigen wochen
eigentlich gar nicht noch gar nicht
damit gerechnet dass es überhaupt so
schnell zum impfen kommen würde das war
ein riesen kraftakt jetzt für die alten
und pflegeheime vor allem
einverständniserklärungen beizubringen
auch für menschen die die demente oder
schwer pflegebedürftig sind aber es ist
gelungen zumindest hier und in vielen
vielen anderen einrichtungen in der
republik und eine alte dame hat mir
heute etwas gesagt dass es ging ans herz
und das war ein sehr schöner ein
hoffnungsvoller satz die impfungen ist
jetzt der große schritt in richtung auf
normalität und heraus aus der einsamkeit
ja das hoffen wir eine vielen dank ralf
zimmermann von sieff hat als zeichen des
europäischen zusammenhalt starteten
heute die eu-mitgliedstaaten
gleichzeitig mit dem impfen
die gemeinsame aktion zugleich ein
aufruf an im skeptiker wir sollten uns
zusammenreißen und das virus
verschwinden lassen sagt diese
96-jährige altenheimbewohnerin den
spanien als erste geimpft wurde
und diese polnische klinik angestellte
sagt dass ich als krankenschwester
zuerst geimpft werde ist eine
anerkennung für alle hart arbeitenden
krankenschwestern und hebammen
alte und schwache menschen kommen in
deutschland an erster stelle
weil ihre widerstandskräfte gegen die
krankheit geringer sind in senioren und
pflegeheimen kein problem wie aber kommt
die anti corona impfspritzen zu den
älteren die nicht dort leben
lena niebergall erklärt wie es mit dem
impfen weitergeht auch sie gehören zur
ersten impf gruppe über 80 jährige die
zu hause leben in ganz deutschland etwa
fünf millionen menschen
sie müssen in ein impfzentrum wenn sie
sich impfen lassen wollen brauchen dafür
einen termin um den muss man sich in den
meisten bundesländern selbst kümmern
telefonisch über eine hotline oder über
eine online-plattform nur in berlin
bremen und mecklenburg vorpommern kommt
eine persönliche einladung
voraussichtlich per post und so läuft
der termin im impfzentrum ungefähr ab
zunächst ausweisen dann eine ärztliche
beratung und untersuchung im anschluss
die impfung selbst zuletzt kurz ausruhen
falls nebenwirkungen auftreten etwa drei
wochen später dann zum zweiten termin
und die impfung ist komplett einige
impfzentren sollen noch vor jahresende
öffnen die meisten aber erst im januar
schauen wir mit den impfungen stellen
sich auch neue fragen soll man
denjenigen die dann gegen korona immun
sind mehr rechte zugestehen
schließlich wäre es ja möglich daß sie
sich mit anderen geimpften treffen ohne
einschränkungen
aber was ist dann mit allen anderen es
sind fragen nach solidarität recht und
gerechtigkeit
julia schröter berichtet
die impfungen sind gestartet nach und
nach kann ein wachsender teil der
bevölkerung theoretisch zurück ins
normale leben
aber sollten geimpfte sonderrechte
bekommen restaurantbesuch oder kino für
ironisierte davon bilder
bundesinnenminister nichts wissen
eine unterscheidung zwischen geimpften
und nicht geimpften komme einer
impfpflicht gleich ich kann nur davor
warnen eine sonderbehandlung für
geimpfte spaltet die gesellschaft
der staat muss neutral bleiben und darf
nicht zum vormund der bürgerinnen und
bürger werden politisch nicht erwünscht
aber wie sieht es rechtlich aus private
betriebe können sich auf das hausrecht
und den grundsatz der vertragsfreiheit
berufen
sie kann sagen wir lassen nur geimpfte
personen eintreten
zwar gibt es das
antidiskriminierungsgesetz was auch für
private gilt das verbietet aber nur eine
benachteiligung wegen des geschlechts
oder wegen der herkunft oder wegen der
religion eine benachteiligung wegen
einer fehlenden impfung ist hingegen
nicht verboten
so einfach ist das bei der deutschen
bahn und deutschen airlines nicht sie
haben eine beförderungspflicht die
lufthansa geht davon aus dass
langstreckenflüge künftig nur mit einem
negativen corona test oder impfnachweis
möglich sein werden
eine generelle impfpflicht wie bei der
australischen airline quantas soll es
nicht geben
wir halten gar nichts davon die große
gruppe der noch nicht geimpften
auszuschließen vom luftverkehr oder von
den verkehrsträgern insgesamt das ist
auch überhaupt nicht nötig stattdessen
setze man auf die geltenden
sicherheitsmaßnahmen
damit sei fliegen sicher die impfungen
gegen das corona virus haben gerade erst
begonnen
die debatte über die folgen aber ist
schon da schauen wir auf die aktuellen
corona zahlen in deutschland
das robert koch institut meldete binnen
24 stunden 13 1755 neuinfektionen in
verbindung mit dem virus sind 356
menschen gestorben
in der weihnachtswoche wird allerdings
weniger getestet und nicht alle
gesundheitsämter übermitteln ihre daten
bundesfinanzminister scholz findet es
richtig dass die senkung der
mehrwertsteuer zum jahresende ausläuft
man habe sie bewusst befristet damit
niemand anschaffungen auf schiebe sagte
scholz der funke mediengruppe zugleich
wies er darauf hin dass das jahr 2021
mit entlastungen beginne
denn für fast alle die steuern zahlen
entfällt nach drei jahrzehnten der
solidaritätszuschlag andreas weise mit
einem rück- und auswege
solidaritätszuschlag kurz soli genannt
dieser posten wird bei den meisten
deutschen auf den lohn- und
gehaltsabrechnungen ab januar nicht mehr
auftauchen umstritten war eingegangen
und darum geht es ja um sich eine
problematik mit den altbundesländern ich
denke ost und west hat davon profitiert
denn auch im westen des vieles mit
diesen solidaritäts zuschlag geschaffen
worden
denn der so divani zweckgebunden 344
milliarden euro sind dadurch seit 1991
aus west und ost in die staatskasse
geflossen das hauptziel die marode
infrastruktur im osten zu verbessern
nach expertenmeinung wurde das erreicht
wenn sie sich die infrastruktur angucken
1990 und die infrastruktur angucken
heute dann sehen sie einen dramatischen
fortschritt und einen vergleichbaren
fortschritt in der infrastruktur sehen
sie natürlich im westen nicht sondern
das niveau waren 90 höher und inzwischen
würde ich sagen haben wir tatsächlich
was die infrastruktur angeht mehr oder
minder gleichstand erreicht
nun ist es nicht so dass der so die
komplett wegfällt nur für ledige mit
einem jährlichen bruttoeinkommen des
73.000 euro ist das so dann steigt der
satz langsam an und wer mehr als 109.000
brutto im jahr hat muss weiterhin den
vollen so die zahlen bei verheirateten
gilt es für einkommen bis 151.000 ab
221.000 euro im jahr
auch unternehmen müssen weiterhin den
soli zahlen aber wie lange noch und ob
es weiter eine sondersteuer sein soll
ist umstritten
die fdp klagt vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht gegen den rest
soli entschieden ist da aber noch nichts
ziemlich ungemütlich war sein diesem
sonntag in einigen regionen deutschlands
grund war sturmtief hermine
das brachte insbesondere an den küsten
starke böen mit sich noch heftiger hat
es am wochenende großbritannien erwischt
dort schickte sturm bella mit
windgeschwindigkeiten von rund 130
kilometern pro stunde und viel regen
über teile von wales und südengland
tausende haushalte waren hier und auch
in frankreich zeitweise ohne strom
ja und nun zu dir norbert und zum
fußball da hat schalke 04 einen neuen
trainer bekommen hatte sich ja schon
angedeutet nun hat es der verein
offiziell bestätigt christian gross ist
der neue cheftrainer der 66 jährige
schweizer war zwischen 2009 und 2010
coach beim vfb stuttgart sein vertrag
läuft vorerst bis zum saisonende
er ist die letzte hoffnung in einer bis
hierhin desaströsen schalker saison
christian gross der vierte trainer bei
s04 in dieser spielzeit wurde am frühen
abend per video konferenz vorgestellt
was ich will dass die spiele mit
zuversicht mit zielstrebigkeit und vor
mit entschlossenheit dass die mission
angehen eine mission die einer
herkulesaufgabe für den nachfolger von
interims trainer huub stevens leicht
saisonübergreifend schalke in der
bundesliga seit 29 spielen ohne sieg
sechs punkte trennen den tabellenletzten
vom relegationsplatz groß bleiben sechs
tage um die mannschaft aufzurichten am
zweiten januar ist schalke bei hertha
bsc berlin zu gast
morgen wäre beginn der 69
vierschanzentournee heute die gute
nachricht für skiflug weltmeister karl
geiger
der oberstdorfer kann seine krone
quarantine verlassen und schon zum
ersten wettbewerb auf seiner heimschanze
antreten
ankunft am mannschaftshotel nach zwei
negativen corona tests
geiger ist zurück pünktlich zu beginn
der tournee ich persönlich fühle mich
gut es ist natürlich die umstände sind
nicht ideal also das ist so und die
letzten sprünge waren doch ziemlich gut
von dem er glaube ich schon dass ich mit
einem guten gefühl jetzt starten kann
seine letzten sprünge vor der quarantäne
waren flüge in planica wurde geiger
weltmeister im skifliegen
sein größter sportlicher triumph da
hätte ich mich selber auf ihrem zettel
geschrieben
da habe ich dadurch gewonnen und ich
weiß schon dass ich auch mit guten
sprüngen dass ich da auch ein wörtchen
mitreden kann
die unterstützung der zuschauer wird
fehlen oberstdorf dieses jahr kein
hexenkessel der fokus wird auf dem puren
sport liegen und der auftrag der
vierschanzen-tournee morgen bei uns im
zdf live ab 16 uhr 10
duncan arbeit 2020 geht zu ende ein jahr
das vor allem die korona pandemie
geprägt hat alles begann hier auf einem
markt in buch hat die chinesische
provinz wird wohl für immer mit dem
virus verbunden werden von hier zieht es
um die welt erschütternde bilder im
august aus beirut eine verheerende
explosion reißt mehr als 190 menschen in
den tod
im herbst präsidentschaftswahlen in den
usa
trump muss gehen beiden kommt und auch
das bleibt von diesem jahr solidarität
und applaus rund um den globus für die
helden der korona pandemie mehr bilder
gibt's gleich im anschluss im album 2020
[Applaus]
[Musik]
heute hat es schon heftig gewehrt wie
wir vorhin hörten aktuell warnt der
deutsche wetterdienst noch vor
orkanartigen böen ganz im süden bayerns
und so sieht es morgen aus viele wolken
im westen etwas sonne
vor allem im süden wird es regnen
oberhalb von 400 metern schneien
höchsttemperatur 0 bis 6 grad
das war es von uns schön dass sie dabei
waren
heute gibt es auch wieder ein journal
mit marietta slomka gegen 23 uhr
wir wünschen noch einen angenehmen abend
und sagen tschüss bis morgen um 7